grace this is our and you didn't die
sorry kid but this has to happen you
play this feature game long enough to
learn some neat tricks
[Music]
that's nice it really does a secret
organization has been operating in
Central City these people they live in
the darkness any absence of light they
will not be brought out of the shadows
easily now that the multiverse is gone
physics has changed entirely worthless
rebuilt I have to do everything I can to
protect them Larry has more threats and
we don't know where they're coming from
something sports you've been acting kind
of different I had to start planning for
a life without you we don't live in
crisis mode anymore I have to expose
this organization out there that can't
be your time someone distressed anymore
with all these changes to our reality
maybe figure out who you want to be in
this post-crisis world the anti-life
equation sorry what it's a
techno-organic poison it's targeted and
transmitted through the big frame it's
really scary man how does such a thing
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new flash season 6
episode 10 trailer the crisis on
Infinite Earths epilogue this is also
happening after the events of the arrow
series finale so we'll explain what's
going on with that because there's a
little bit of crossover that's
continuing in the back half of the
season it wholly anti-life equation it
looks like Darkseid is on the horizon
for the DC TV universe if you're
introducing the anti-life equation like
they name drop during that clip then it
makes sense that you would build up to
something like the new gods if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the easter egg
videos we're doing a new flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from crisis on the video so we'll
just break all this down top 10 style
starting with number 10 the title of
this episode is going to be marathon but
it won't air till the beginning of
February so like I said it's airing
after the arrow serious finale they have
a big funeral for Oliver I'll talk about
that in a second the title of the
episode is marathon the official
synopsis just reads after the citizen
Irish's newspaper Prince an explosive
story about black hole Iris's life is
threatened refusing to hide from those
that are attacking her iris sets out to
expose a dangerous organization
obviously talking about black hole from
the comics
meanwhile Barry must face the
consequences of crisis and fulfill
Oliver Queen's wish for him so number
nine that's where you see Barry visiting
Diggle at Argus sitting inside some
weird prison cell here I don't know why
they're sitting inside a prison cell
talking about Oliver some of the you
might remember this Easter Egg for the
mask the Diggle is handing back to Barry
so Barry's holding Oliver's Green Arrow
mask but the reason why Diggle would be
giving that to him is because Barry way
back when they started crossing over is
the person who gave Oliver that mask so
it's sort of like Diggle is giving him
back the mask that he gave to Oliver
just like this heirloom between the two
of them that has a lot of meaning number
8 WTF Barry's hand starts giving off all
kinds of weird speed force energy that's
probably the consequences that they
refer to so they changed the timeline
meaning that they changed a bunch of
stuff that we just haven't learned about
yet we'll find out in future episodes
so that might just mess a little bit
with Barry's connection to the Speed
Force he's getting more powerful but he
doesn't totally understand everything
that happened after crisis like they
changed a few things and they learned
about that like they're all in the same
earth now but there's also a lot of
other things that got changed that he
just hasn't figured out yet the energy
he gives off also looks a little bit
like Earth 90 Barry Allen when he was
stealing Barry's speed like he said
you've been a speedster as long as I
have you learned a couple new tricks
there was also a bit of a teaser for
future abilities that they'll unlock on
the flash there's a lot of comic book
abilities that the flash has that they
haven't done on a TV show yet the number
7 WTF iris narrates how crisis on
Infinite Earths is over and Barry didn't
die like the Future newspaper said
because earth 90 Barry Allen took his
place after stealing his speed and just
to be clear that's just John Wesley
ships earth 90 Barry Allen flash that
died not Jay Garrick so John Wesley
Shipp still plays the character who's
alive on the show on earth 3 and who
recently started getting busy with a
version of Tina McGee that looks just
like Barry's mother so there is a happy
ending for John Wesley Shipp the actor
in all this I'm also hoping that he
cameos during the flash movie - but I
don't know who he would play during the
movie I don't know if they're gonna let
him play a character as big as Jay
Garrick in the DC movies but they just
remains to be seen it's gonna be a
couple years before we see the flash
movie I talked a little bit about that
in my last crisis on Infinite Earths
video when they did the Ezra Miller
scene crossing over with a Grant Gustin
flash so I'll post a link to that at the
end of this
but number six now the crisis is over
Barry and iris think that all the super
hardcore problems are taken care of and
making Netflix and chill for the rest of
the season like oh there might be some
villains that pop up but for the most
part the crisis is gone we don't have to
worry about this dark future but then
they officially introduced the black
hole storyline from the flash rebirth
comics you also notice this Easter Egg
here to the news broadcaster isn't
broadcasting from channel 52 it's
Channel 8 that's also another Easter Egg
for some of the changes they made
combining all of the earths
into earth Prime the 52 Easter Egg from
way back because they've been doing that
since arrow season 1 was a reference to
the new 52 universe of the DC Universe
in the second big crisis event called
Infinite Crisis not the same thing as
crisis on Infinite Earths number 5
during Infinite Crisis during the early
2000s alexander luthor created a new
cosmic tower using the anti-monitor
power to try and bring back his earth
that he lost the version of the
multiverse that they brought back during
that event only had 52 different earths
then they had the flash flashpoint
storyline they made a couple more
changes to their timeline and that's
then what's referred to as the new 52
era of DC Comics so any time you're
watching old episodes of arrow or the
flash and you see channel 52 on the news
broadcast that's what that's referencing
the last big DC comic book event to
change the multiverse was DC Reaper they
also dropped an Easter Egg for that when
Oliver rebooted the universe he said we
have to rebirth the universe so number 4
you have the events of the arrow season
8 finale the series finale very last
episode that's happening next week
there's a bunch of teasers and preview
pictures that they drop for that you see
them bringing back dead people most
notably Oliver's mother that's one of
the many changes that they probably made
to the timeline when they brought the
universes back there's probably a whole
bunch of other cameos for that episode
but there's an important reason why the
flash episode isn't premiering till
after the arrow series finale just
because a lot of what you see happening
during this next episode of the flash
addresses all the stuff from the arrow
finale number three it seems like
somebody has the bright idea to turn the
particle accelerator on again for the
billionth time and you see the black
hole assassin chick chasing down patch
face here who just seems like a common
thug and they introduced this big
cover-up storyline
irises news team starts to investigate
black hole who according to the trailer
has been operating out of Central City
in secret this whole time since before
the beginning of flash season one that
means that the reverse-flash probably
knew about them and didn't say anything
just because they weren't a threat to
his plans and it would only complicate
things to let them know about it before
he was ready to make his move
it seems like the black hole assassin
then starts going after team flash to
silence all of them she goes after Jo
she comes after iris Cisco says the
earth has more threats that they don't
know about don't know where they're
coming from they bring back Katee
Sackhoff Amunet black character the
chicks fighting each other in black
leather just seemed like more black hole
agents going at it then this woman here
looking at her reflection in the shard
of the mirror might be their new version
of mirror master I don't know which
episode she's supposed to debut in
number two WTF Wally West is coming back
in the back half of the season for a big
reverse flash episode I think it's gonna
be season 6 episode 14 so it's not gonna
be this next episode they'll probably
use that episode to address what
happened with reverse flash during
crisis now I explained in real life the
reason why they didn't include him but
the character himself will explain where
he's been and why he wasn't around
probably hiding out inside the negative
Speed Force because that protects him
from the timeline changes it would have
also protected him from the antimatter
wave they also kind of implied that
Wally might wind up fridging reverse
flash during his episode they say
permanently defeat so that could mean a
lot of different things but obviously
number one big WTF is the name drop of
the anti-life equation all the new gods
all the darkside implications they name
dropped it on Supergirl during the
episode that happens right after a
crisis on Infinite Earths this past week
so I'm assuming that they're just
building towards eventual new gods story
and they'll play handle that in a future
crossover we're not in the Smallville
era anymore they kind of did a version
of Darkseid on the Smallville TV show if
you're gonna do character is big as
Darkseid because of the anti-life
equation you would do that for a huge
huge crossover story so everyone post
your theories in the comments below if
they're using anti-life equation this
early in the story when do you think
they'll actually pay that off with some
new gods story there's been a bunch of
big Marvel x-men news recently so I'll
try to do a video for that as soon as
possible but leave all your requests in
the comments
below everyone click here for that scene
of the Ezra Miller flash in crisis on
Infinite Earths crossing over with the
Grant Gustin flash favorite moment hands
down and click here for all my other
crisis on Infinite Earths
episode videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you
[Music]